[Music]
please welcome drew barrymore
[Applause]
thank you guys so much welcome welcome
welcome
to the show
i would love to spend the next hour
having a blast figuring out the good
stuff in life having many different
kinds of conversation and i really like
getting some good news because it's just
nice to know and sometimes you really
need it so let's hit the headlines
[Applause]
it's time for truth
news ring-a-ding-ding on the good news
telly and with me at the desk is a fine
chap indeed ross matthew hello hi
hi
all right well let's jump into the news
we all know that pandemic pets were a
huge phenomenon but there's so many
cuties who still need homes shelters and
rescue
they use every tool in the box to get
pets adopted including
insanely cute names the washington post
reports that an adorable name can really
get a pet noticed
that's right there's even a twitter
account pet finder names that highlight
the cream of the crop let's check out ed
sheeran
oh yeah
that's cute
i mean it
this works yeah look at adam sandler the
gecko who doesn't want a sandler oh
right yeah i would love it to get in
creative and do like brad pitbull
caddy perry
exactly and the good news is as much as
you know rescues always need support the
pandemic did have some positive news
that so many pets did get adopted they
did and this name this is oh it's like
we have rest give me the good news
well i actually um i have a little
surprise for you um i love surprises i
know you do well you're gonna love this
it's a duo from rough start rescue in
princeton minnesota they're special
because they're these two little kittens
these are brothers and sisters they're
what they call a bonded pair which means
they have to be adopted together because
they love each other so much and do you
know what they have named these two
little kittens drew this brother and
sister
meet drew barrymore and ross matthews
they legit
named them after us
and they tell us that ross is a little
nervous nelly
[Laughter]
and drew is braver and calmer than
ross
wait is this is real yeah that they
named them after us do and and they're
up for adoption which one's which okay
let's okay let's take a look can we
bring him back up
there's drew
and and the kitty is raw ross there's
ross you can tell because a little gray
oh my gosh
oh i mean we're gonna have to do
something about that now are you gonna
get more pets well my daughter does want
another cat um we already have two i i
this is why dr drew little was actually
born because
i our family has six chickens two cats
two dogs
one fish
um and our bearded dragon named jeremy
i i swear i think i'm forgetting some
yeah um
we did have guinea pigs but we found
homes for them
because i was like i can't take this
anymore so i've become literally the
insane person with the menagerie like it
just i i i was like we gotta find these
guinea pigs homes i i can't
daisy who is such a grump too but she we
found her a loving home what is a grumpy
guinea pig like
well i don't think any of them are that
enthusiastic um
but
they're sort of introverts
yes but i i was like we gotta find you
know a home that's like not so busy and
can focus on daisy so we found a home
for daisy good thrilled for daisy yeah
but i'm we gotta
i i think we should check into the cat
situation because
which dog one of your daughters wants
another cat that's why doctor yes all of
it it's it's some of it's for her some
of it's for me i ended up taking care of
them
we're going to check in with those okay
all right how cute though i know you'd
love that yeah well our next story comes
from some pet owners in chicago when
nicole sopko and dan stackman's beloved
dog greta passed away last spring it we
all know how hard that can be it was a
few months before they found freda an
eight-year-old from texas who needed a
home and people reports the couple ran a
doggy dna test on her and they get this
they found out that frida and greta
were shockingly
cousins
what
yes
nicole and dan say it confirmed what
they already knew in their hearts that
frida was meant to be
a part of their family and this i can't
even why is this not an animated movie
drew barrymore
don't you have power come on let's make
this happen i'll call netflix
do you know what's so funny a part of me
is listening to this story and i'm so
happy like this is definitely should be
a movie but i'm like oh there is no way
i'm getting dna tests for all the
animals at my house i'll be running a
lab and i'm like guess what you came
from jersey you i don't know
north valley
hollywood
you know like wherever you came from you
came from moving on well i did do dna
tests on my three rescue dogs of course
you did of course they did because hello
but there they are
yeah that's selena audrey and pa earl
named after my great-grandpa paw earl
and you know what the dna that's you
know what the dna test told me
that they're chihuahuas
thanks so much for that science i maybe
i didn't pay for the upgrade where you
can find out if they're cousins but i
just picture us like on maury povich and
him being like you are not the breeder
yeah
i'll show douglas and lucy um i i they
came they're from california and uh i'm
like wherever they're from cat fillmore
lucy came from fillmore douglas from
north hollywood north hollywood yeah
okay yeah
um
um okay well that's that's interesting
pet dna
well maybe when you rescue ross matthews
and drew barrymore we can test their dna
maybe
[Music]